sur des centaines de mètres des toits
effondrés
des façades éventrées
nous sommes dans le petit village
d'octobre ce qui ici c'est la guerre je
l'aimé c'est la guerre quand même et le
danger ce sont les snipers bien sûr
qu'ils peuvent nous avoir le crâne n'est
qu'à 800 mètres par là bas je ne vais
pas plus loin
j'ai des petits enfants en bas âge
les combats ici ont été particulièrement
violents 2014 2015 pour prendre
l'aéroport
dont il ne reste que cette ruine au loin
depuis octobre ce qui a des allures de
village fantôme
dans ce quartier il n'y a que deux
familles et c'est tout
qu'est ce qui s'est passé il ya eu des
guerres l'ukraine a détruit le nom basse
une partie du dombass est contrôlé
depuis huit ans par des séparatistes des
affrontements avec les forces de kiev se
poursuivre le long de la ligne de
contact c'est là que vit et les nader
cacho va au milieu des maisons
abandonnées
impossible de partir en hâte qu'on n'a
pas d'argent vous comprenez je n'ai pas
d'argent
alors elle reste ici contrainte et
forcée à deux kilomètres de la ligne de
front
c'est tombé là on a dû changer les
fenêtres les bombes sont tombées juste
là tout a été détruit par là en ce
moment les combats sont plus rares mais
la peur est toujours là
bien sûr que nous avons peur
rostom mais personne ne s'occupe de nous
ni comment
elle a tenu à nous faire entrer chez
elle pour nous montrer quelque chose
c'est la cave là où on se cache
quelques mètres carrés ou descente toute
la famille à la moindre alerte
moi je m'assois ici avec mon fils là
c'est ma mère là ma grand mère bien sûr
que c'est dur de se cacher avec un
enfant c'est pas seulement difficile cet
inquiétant il n'a pas peur mais ils
demandent quand les hommes vont arrêter
de faire des gros bruit
dans ce village personne ni rien ne
semble avoir été épargnées par la guerre
cette ancienne église a été détruite en
2014 2015 après d'intenses combats des
combattants séparatistes s'était réfugié
ici vous le voyez juste à côté on a
commencé à reconstruire une nouvelle
église et peu importe que la ligne de
front ne soit qu'à quelques centaines de
mètres dans cette direction